besoin urgent d'argent 500 750 ville 250
dollars aucune enquête de crédit
réponse en une heure dépôts qui détient
cette pub
aperçue dans le métro vous dit elle la
vérité toute la vérité
non nous avons découvert la face cachée
de cette publicité
lorsqu'on appelle l'agent nous parle
d'un taux d'intérêt annuel de 28 pour
cent mais attention il ajoute qu'il ya
aussi des frais de courtage 240 $ pour
un prêt de 500 $ claire emprunté 500 $
vous coûter environ 800 dollars pour un
emprunt de 750 $ vous devrez remettre
environ 1200 dollars la loi sur la
protection du consommateur est très
claire les frais de courtage doivent
être ajoutées aux taux d'intérêt pour
calculer ce qu'on appelle le taux de
crédit annuel d'après l'office de la
protection du consommateur
le taux de crédit annuel des prêts de
500 et 750 $ de brest en point comme
aussi entre 225 et 300 c est pour ça
reste en point comme une solution facile
et rapide à vos problèmes d'argent rien
n'est moins sûr